resignado a su destino blanco quiso dar
su último mensaje desde su cama
y comienza el camino a la liberación y
créanme soy feliz aquí vamos ahora
es la despedida para quienes no me verán
de nuevo
y así es la vida adiós
el hombre que padece una enfermedad
incurable tomo la decisión el viernes de
dejar de comer y de finalizar su
tratamiento y luego emitir su propia
muerte en redes sociales algo que
facebook le prohibió
los casos sobre el derecho a morir han
sido una intensa polémica en francia el
más sonado fue el de banzo lambea quien
quedó en estado vegetativo tras un
accidente en 2008 murió en julio de 2019
luego de que los médicos lo
desconectaran tras una larga batalla
legal en el centro de estas disputas hay
desacuerdos sobre la ley leonetti de
2005 la ley permite la llamada eutanasia
pasiva que es cuando la muerte ocurre
por la interrupción de los tratamientos
la norma fue actualizada en 2016 y se
autorizó la sedación letal pero
solamente para quienes tengan un mal
pronóstico a corto plazo
sin embargo provocar la muerte
deliberadamente para cesar el
sufrimiento a través de una eutanasia
activa sigue prohibido
para saltarse estas leyes algunos
pacientes van a bélgica países bajos
luxemburgo donde la eutanasia es legal